this is a fierce battle and
reinforcements are sorely needed
military medical staff drafted from
Shanghai to go to Wuhan the epicenter of
this epidemic Ground Zero ten days ago
there are only 41 cases of novel
coronavirus now there are more than
1,200 officials in Hubei have said they
are running low on medical supplies and
hospitals have made their own Appeals
for donations from the public the city
is on ever-greater lockdown with cars
now banned 56 million people in the
region are under a travel ban so we were
shown pictures of the Chinese Politburo
in action including President Xi
Jingping it might not see much but it's
rare for chinese state media to
broadcast meetings like this the aim is
to show how seriously the leadership is
taking the outbreak even if none of them
has yet visited Wuhan the rest of China
is closing off Disneyland Shanghai
should be packed over the New Year's
break instead is empty this was already
ambitious to build a thousand bed
hospital from scratch in less than a
week but authorities have decided it
will not be enough a second bigger
hospital has been commissioned each hour
seems to bring a new measure from the
Chinese government and that seems to
offer the opposite of reassurance if the
response is like this how big must the
danger be Tom Cheshire sky knees Beijing